we've been discussing uh in the program
today the unease among many conservative
mps who are
deeply unhappy about the new tier system
of restrictions that will be brought in
in
england on wednesday boris johnson has
suggested that millions of people could
come out of the top tier in mid-december
and he also promised that mps will get
another vote in the new year but is it
enough
uh to placate the unhappy conservatives
well joining us now is one concerned
backbencher
pauline latham thank you very much for
being with us this morning so the prime
minister has written
two mps to try and reassure them about
this new tier system
has he done enough to make you feel
better about it
well he certainly certainly changed a
tone
and i think that's partly due to the
fact that we've got a new regime in
number 10
and he is listening much more to mps
than he was in the past
so that's a good thing and my concern
really is that there are many many
hospitality businesses that have spent
tens of thousands of pounds
making themselves covert secure and yet
they can't open
i mean where i live here in mid
derbyshire we we
reluctantly but willingly went into tier
two
before lockdown we've had lockdown and
now we're in tier three
so many of those businesses um in the
country not just here
will not survive if they can only open
for five days of christmas
that's not enough to compensate them for
what they have lost
over the run-up to christmas because
that's what they rely on
i'm not saying everybody should be going
out and going into hospitality
businesses
but the younger people and those who are
safe who could go
those who are older can stay at home if
that's what they choose to do
but there has to be a balance and i'm i
mean i'm very saddened
um by the fact that in this area and
further north we're in
tier three because i think that the r
rate has come down
and therefore we are in a much better
place than we were before lockdown
and yet we're in tier three and it's a
difficult thing
to persuade people to abide by i mean i
am
trying to persuade people i'm trying to
talk to people to say we've got to do
this
but actually i'm concerned because of
the businesses that will go
to the wall due to this and the extra
suicides and all the other depression
the elderly people who can't see their
families as much as they'd like to
it's all a very difficult situation
so it's clear you have some real
concerns about the impact on your own
constituency and also more widely
and does this mean that on tuesday when
mps will vote
on the tier system are you going to be
supporting the government
well i'd like to see the data i'd like
to see their evidence
more evidence than we've been given if
we can see that
then i do feel i might be able to
support them
particularly as we're looking at having
another vote in january
but for some of those businesses nine
weeks is a very very long time when they
should be making a lot of money
christmas
new year that's when they need to make
their money to carry them through the
quieter months of january february
and it's it's not just hospitality it's
also retail they need
people to be able to go through the
shops and spend money which they can do
they will they will be able to do that
but hospitality is much harder
so i'd like to see the opportunity to
vote before
nine weeks is up i but i do genuinely
want to see the evidence i want to see
that data
that the prime minister is basing his
decisions on
and he's got a difficult job i'm not
decrying his job is really hard
but i don't believe he can just listen
to the medics he has to
listen to people in the economy we've
we've seen rishi tsunak do an amazing
job he's thought outside of the box
he saved a lot of jobs and he said he
can't save them all
i accept that but hospitality is a huge
huge industry and once it's gone it'll
be hard for it to come back it will come
back
but it might take several years before
it comes back there'll be new people
want to take up those businesses
that's the nature of things but i don't
want to see the people currently
employed i'm working really hard to make
it safe for people
to go to the wall now at the same time
you talked about your own constituency
starting off in tier two before lockdown
and ending up in tier three
but isn't that the whole point the
restrictions weren't tough enough before
and that's why we ended up
in a lockdown you can understand can't
you why things have to be titans
yes i mean it is difficult i accept that
it's very difficult but if we're told if
it's
true that we're told that the r rate has
come down we've always been told right
from the beginning of the pandemic
that once see our rate goes below one
then we're in a much better place
the r8 was above one quite a way above
one before the lockdown it's now below
one
so why have we gone into a higher tier
than we were before
we need to be in tier two i think
everybody could live with tier two
we can we can work around that and that
gives hospitality businesses
the opportunity to trade although i have
to say
wet pubs it's difficult for them because
they can't always
supply what's called a substantial meal
but i'd like to see
relaxation on that so that people can go
to the pub
socially distance secure sitting at
tables
that are distance away from others and
served at the table
it won't be the same experience as
normal but at least it would be an
opportunity for people to go out
and damien green another concept mp is
written in the sunday times today saying
i've been in parliament for 23 years
and it's hard to remember a time when
i've seen so much anger both with the
way that mps are being consulted about
their areas
and at the way our constituents are
being forced to lead their lives
and you obviously speak to your
colleagues all the time
um how strong is that anger and how many
people do you think
are actually willing to break the whip
i think it'll depend very much on uh
what boris does between now and tuesday
if he produces that evidence and he can
prove to us
that he's got good evidence to go on
then i think
he won't have a rebellion but i think
there will be
so a lot of people i don't know how many
and you say i talk to people all the
time sadly we're so socially distanced
in parliament everyone's heard about the
what's up groups
yes there's what's up groups people are
not happy
and i've certainly been contacted not
just by hospitality businesses by
constituents who don't want to live this
way
now obviously older people it's more
dangerous for them so they don't have to
go out
nobody's making them go out nobody's
saying you must go
to a pub but i think there needs to be
freedom for those people lots of people
live on their own these days
it's really really tough for them and
mps are only reflecting what their
constituents are saying to them
okay and we're out of time thank you
very much for being on the program
this morning paulie latham there